Luffy has just found the one piece and
the final war that will determine the
fate of the world is about to begin the
world's government itself is on the
brink of collapse and in a last-ditch
effort to get rid of Luffy they're
willing to bet every last piece of gold
that they have to issue the highest
bounties the world has ever seen but
just how crazy will the straw Hat's
final bounties at the end of the story
actually be starting off with the cruise
doctor Chomper it's a reoccurring joke
in the series that Chopper always has a
laughably low Bounty the Marines have
always thought that Chopper being a
reindeer is simply the straw Hat's pet
first he had a bounty of 50 berries it
then doubled to 100 and then it
multiplied by 10 all the way to the
incredible sum of 1 000 berries however
surely by the end of the series someone
in the world government will catch on to
this reindeer's genius level of
intellect and so for Chopper this
amazing doctor has the dream of curing
every disease in the world and while
this is a very positive thing for the
world it is all also indispensable for
the straw hat crew and so ironically
Chopper poses a really huge risk to the
world government because he can heal and
cure any of the straw hats when they
face any type of injury or disease and
you see Ichiro the author of One Piece
absolutely loves to use wordplay with
his numbers that he uses in the series
and so Chopper's devil fruit the hito
hitonomi or human human fruit can
actually also be read as stole as in the
Japanese word for the number one and
therefore I only think it makes sense
that Chopper's final bouncy would also
include Stone 1-1 in honor of his devil
fruit and that's why I'm going to
multiply his current bouncy by 1000
which will bring him to 1 million
berries but for good measure we're going
to throw in an extra 100 000 that brings
Chopper's bouncy to one million 100
000 berries and someday when the striats
finally reach the one piece they'll only
make it there due to nami's navigation
skills as the straw hats Navigator they
literally couldn't get anywhere without
her the only reason they're able to
Brave the perilous Seas of the one piece
world is through her expert
understanding of the weather and the
landscape and so therefore hugely
increasing her current Bounty makes
sense due to the danger she presents to
the world governments now to be fair as
a fighter Nami has long been one of the
weakest members of the straw hat crew
and has always had a hard time holding
herself against the members of yonko
Cruz however after recruiting big mom's
Cloud homie Zeus to her side she has
become a more threatening fighter than
ever and so it might seem extreme to
bring Nami of all people above 1 billion
berries but we have to remember these
are the bounties of the pirate King's
crew and possibly the last bounties that
the world government will ever be able
to put out also I of course expect that
her bouncy poster will follow the exact
same pattern as it always has previously
each time an undercover Marine
photographer will ask her for her poses
for the photos which she then always is
more than happy to model for now somehow
she still hasn't caught on that these
photographers aren't in it for good
looks but that she's actually posing in
for the most glamorous bouncy posters in
the high seas and so taking all of this
into account nami's final Bounty is
going to raise from 366 million to 1
billion 172 million berries and moving
on once he leads an army of giants
Gustav will become a brave Warrior of
the Seas once the straw hats will sail
to elbaf he'll use his connections to
the Giants that he's met so far like
Kashi oimo Dorian bragi to forge an
alliance and end up leading a whole Army
of Giants against the world's Government
after Feats like this the world
government will have no other choice but
to put a bounty on usop's head that
exceeds 1 billion berries as well and
that of course will be comedy gold
because Usopp is the one straw hat that
actively wants his bounty to decrease
every time he gets a higher Bounty he
freaks out and would very much not like
the world government to be after his
heads but despite his best efforts his
Feats whether accidental or not keep
pushing his Bounty Higher and Higher and
after freeing the dress Rosa prisoners
and after being worshiped as God Usopp
he gained a bounty of 200 million
berries he even had the God usop name
put on his wanted poster and after wano
he's considered an important crew member
of a yonko crew and raised to 500
million berries now it's not really out
of the ordinary for a yonko crew member
to have a bounty of 1 billion or higher
while usop's strength at least right now
doesn't justify this high of a number
the government won't know how weak usop
actually is in a head-to-head battle all
they'll know is that he has an army of
Giants at his disposal and who knows
maybe the theory that USA will awaken
conquerors hockey will actually turn out
to be true in the end as well and so by
the end of the story I want usob to have
a bouncy of 1 billion 100 million but
wow if usop's Bounty actually turns out
to be over a billion just imagine how
high Luffy's will be by the end of the
series moving on I'm surprised that
Brook's Bounty poster actually says Dead
or Alive because I mean he's already
dead but we're not here to talk about
that part of the wanted poster we're
here to talk about the bouncy now
already in the story broke the ship's
musician is one of the biggest
celebrities in the one piece Story the
Rockstar Soul King Brooke is loved by
music fans all across the oceans and how
will it make the straw hats look once
people find out that their favorite rock
star is a member of their crew people
all over the world will have an even
more favorable view of the straw hats
than they already do which means that
Brooke is a big threat to people's
willingness to go along with the world
government's wishes and on top of all
that Brooke is a powerful fighter on the
straw hat crew and was even able to
survive a solo battle against pigma and
while he was obviously defeated due to
her overwhelming strength the fact that
he was even able to land a few scratches
on one of her homies is a true Testament
power and so one day the world
government will most likely realize just
how strong broke actually is and this
isn't even mentioning his stealth and
spying abilities as well if it ever
becomes common knowledge that Brooke can
actually use his Spirit form to spy on
enemies without ever being noticed his
danger to the government will be
considered even higher all of these
reasons come together to make his final
bouncy of 1 billion 430 million berries
why 430 million well because Brooks
deviled through to the yomi yomi Nomi
could also be read as yo me or for three
therefore it's only right that 43
appears in his Bounty somewhat moving on
to cyborg Frankie the ship ride of the
straw hat crew that has finally met his
inventor Idol Dr vegapunk and by the end
of the story I think it's fair to expect
that he'll either learn from vegapunk's
technology or even surpass his Idol to
be specific there is a 99.9 chance that
we're going to see Frankie pilot a giant
Mecca Soldier against the world
government and even without a giant
robot Frankie's one of the strongest
fighters on the crew already existing
Frankie inventions like General Frankie
or Frankie Shogun are powerful enough to
fight super strong Pirates earning him a
current Bounty of 394 million after all
he did deserve a huge Bounty increase
after he motorcycle big mom right in the
face and after all in the same way that
Nami is invaluable to the crew to her
navigation skills the straw hats
wouldn't be able to make their Voyage
without their ship the Thousand Sunny
Frankie not only built this ship but
he's also constantly repairing its
damage as well as giving it powerful
upgrades and we already saw how hard the
world government came down on Tom
Frankie's stepfather the ship ride for
gold Roger ship so imagine how severely
he'd be punished if he was actually
Roger's crewmates and that in itself is
already worth of a huge Bounty so by the
end of the story Frankie will have a
bouncy of 1 billion
832 million berries which brings us to
jimbei the Knight of the sea the former
captain of the sun pirate and a former
warlord but despite all of these crazy
former titles jimbei is now first and
foremost the Helmsman of the straw hat
crew now the world government needs to
be prepared to defend themselves at Sea
because in the final war they'll have to
deal with Legions of fishmen and sea
Kings being led by jimbi after wano
jimbei already has a billion Barry
Bounty since he is already over a
billion there's only one way to go up he
is undoubtedly one of the fiercest
fighters of the straw hat crew as a
Fishman he is Unstoppable in the ocean
with the ability to take out entire
ships with one attack from his Fishman
karate on top of that he is a great
leader and strategist who can step in
when Luffy is otherwise occupied after
all he was already the captain of
another famous and Powerful pirate crew
his desire for Fishman Liberation and
freeing people all across the world
stands strongly opposed to the world
government's wishes making him a huge
threat to their established order and is
one of the strongest crew members and
one of the most respected individuals
across across the entire one piece World
when they will receive a bounty of 2.5
billion berries by the end of the story
and admittedly Robin maybe isn't as
powerful as jimbei but she poses the
biggest threat to the world government
out of the entire crew with maybe just
the exception of Luffy because once she
uncovers the true history of the world
one of the only people who can read the
opponent lives the world government will
be even more desperate to capture her
than ever after all revealing this truth
to the world will probably cause a
worldwide Revolution and so if knowledge
really is power Robin is one of the most
powerful characters in one piece she's
also destroyed's direct connection to
the Revolutionary Army she has directly
worked with monkey the dragon and Sabo
probably being even closer to them than
Luffy is even aware though Luffy is
dragon's actual son and so I think it's
certain that when it's time to topple
the world government Robin will be one
person who's gonna lead the charge after
all the revolutionaries were inspired to
form after the destruction of Ohara of
which Robin is the last Survivor and
while she was staying with the
revolutionaries she has also received
plenty of combat training as well even
though she's not as strong as the top
fighters of the straw hat crew she can
definitely hold her own having defeated
black Maria one of kaido's flying six
and so the government knows exactly just
how much of a thread Robin actually is
having tried to capture her entire life
which is why the devil child will earn a
2 billion 870 million Berry bouncy which
brings us to Sanji one of the wings of
the pirate king he is one of the straw
Hat's strongest crew members able to
fight Toe to Toe literally with yonko
commanders like kaido's third in command
Queen after wano he's unlocked power-ups
from his latent German Powers activated
by his raid suit that have made him even
more powerful than he already was while
other crew members excel in fighting
directly in the final war Sanji is sure
to use his other skill set as well and
that's because Sanji is a master of
strategy and stealth and certainly will
see Mr Prince Again by the end of one
piece Mr Prince is the secret identity D
that samsi used for spycraft and using
his intellect he was able to foil the
plans of cunning characters like sir
crocodile he's already used all these
skills against the world government when
he allowed the crew to escape and his
Lobby by opening the gate of justice for
instance and were sure to see them again
so Sanji just like Robin spells trouble
for the world government as a prince of
the German Kingdom he's the only
character we've ever seen with an only
alive Bounty poster as a member of one
of the 40 kingdoms that formed the world
government he poses a huge threat and
after the events of whole cake Island he
will likely be able to Rally all of the
forces of German 66 against the
government in the final war this current
Bounty is over a billion but I predict
that by the end of the story he will
achieve at least a bounty of 3 billion
berries equivalent to Luffy's current
bouncy after all the sun in Sanji is the
Japanese word for three and so it only
makes sense that it would be included in
his final bouncy but if Sanji will catch
up to Luffy's already huge bounty though
what does that say about how ridiculous
Luffy's bounty will become but by the
time of the final war Zorro won't just
be the right-hand man of the pirate king
he'll be the world's greatest swordsman
and one of the strongest character in
the entire world after he finally
defeats dracul mihawk there will be no
question of Zorro's immense power and
also by the end Zorro is sure to upgrade
his swords to have at least one supreme
grade blade in addition to that since he
has conquerors hockey he's almost
certain to infuse his swords with haki
to create more black blades as well and
so for all these reasons the Marines
will issue a bouncy of at least 3
billion and one Berry yes this number is
a single Berry above sanji's Bounty and
nothing would make Sanji more Furious
than having his final bouncy be lower
than Zoros even if it's just by a single
Berry this would be a top tier joke from
Oda who's already playing a lot into the
Sanji vs sorrow Dynamic and we don't
think he'd pass on the opportunity for
such a committee moments Zara and Sanji
have been really closed in powers and
always been at each other throats but
all in all Zoro does deserve the higher
Bounty even if just by a little bit
after all he's been with Luffy from the
start of the adventure and has been
willing to sacrifice everything for his
captain which finally brings us to the
captain of the straw hat crew because
Luffy will follow in his Father's
Footsteps and become the most wanted man
in the world he will also take after the
former pirate king Goldie Roger and earn
the highest Bounty the world government
has ever officially issues why well he's
the man who attacked and his Lobby he is
the man who punched a Celestial Dragon
he's the man who coordinated the largest
prison break in impel down history he
joined whitebeard's war against Marine
Fort he's an emperor of the sea having
taken down kaido and he's the inheritor
of the Nika Nika fruit the next Joy boy
and the warrior of Liberation when Luffy
becomes pirate king and finds the one
piece he will bring the dawn of the
world and he will very likely topple the
world government's Powers destroy
mourinhoa and end the celestial dragon's
rule for all of this and much much more
we're tempted to give him the highest
Bounty ever at just above Goldie Roger
Roger's Bounty was 5.5 billion so Luffy
could suitably be 5.6 billion berries
after all 56 is often associated with
Luffy because it works with the Japanese
wordplay for gulmu 456 however wait wait
however we all know that Luffy doesn't
have the gomukomonomi there is no such
fruit as the gumugumunumi like Chopper
he has the model of the hiko hitonomi
the human human fruit model Nika and as
we discussed earlier the wordplay for
hiso is one so it also won one we're
having fun here so let's predict an
absolutely absurd Bounty for Luffy and
after over 20 years I want to see Luffy
be the first person ever in one piece to
cross a 10 billion Berry Bounty so that
the Marines have to put every last piece
of gold they have on the table and so
I'm gonna predict that by the end of the
series Luffy will have a bounty of 11
billion 565 million 600
000 berries now of course all of this is
just an educated guess so if you want to
see the newly updated 21 official
highest Bounties in one piece you can
watch that video right here thanks so
much for hanging out with me today if
you had fun or learned anything do me a
favor like subscribe comment share I
know it's annoying to hear me ask for
that but it really helps out the Channel
and like most topics we cover on this
channel today's topic was also
recommended by you if there's any topic
you'd like to see or learn more about
just leave me a comment under this video
thanks